today we're going to have to cancel
harry styles again or perhaps it's not
so much harry styles we're canceling as
the legions of
cult-like plebes who pretend that
everything he does is brilliant and
beautiful
you probably recall the ruckus last week
when styles appeared in a magazine in
women's clothes
and candace owens who will soon be
having a show here on the daily wire
dared to suggest that men should not be
wearing
skirts and dresses and should instead be
masculine as god and nature intended
well the story sort of died down until
yesterday when stiles issued a clap back
to owens now i use the term clap back
because that is the term used by
literally
dozens of news outlets in their
headlines about the story just google
harry styles clapback and then you know
put hit hit the news button
dozens of these uh of these headlines
harry styles claps back at candace owens
they use that term because we live in an
exceedingly stupid society
where once self-respecting news outlets
use teenage lingo in their headlines
but in any case um here is harry styles
and his clapback
his i'm told devastating brilliant
genius
incredible life-changing historic
clapback
possibly the cleverest comeback in the
history of comebacks and here it is it's
an it's an instagram post of harry
styles
and what appears to be seinfeld's puffy
shirt
or there might be a blouse stitched
together from his grandmother's
tablecloth i'm not sure
and he's eating a banana and the caption
says
bring bring back manly men
which is what candace owens had said so
that's a clap back
now a few things here first of all are
we really going to pretend
that this man doesn't look stupid as
hell in that ridiculous outfit
the problem here is not that it's
womanly i've never seen a woman dress
like that
or any human if my wife walked into the
room
wearing that i would immediately stage
an intervention assuming that she's high
on heroin
second i want you to imagine something
for a moment just
imagine what would happen if a white
conservative male celebrity
what few exist were to issue a clap back
to a black liberal woman with a picture
of himself
eating a banana imagine how that would
be received
imagine what assumptions would be made
you know we're at a point right now
where you can simply move your fingers a
certain way you can make a a circle with
your index and thumb like this
and you'll be accused of sending racist
messages right now
i'm sending a racist message supposedly
almost anything is a racist dog whistle
these days so how is this picture of a
guy eating a banana
meant as a diss to a black woman not a
racist dog whistle
now to be clear i don't actually think
that harry styles meant it that way
um i don't really want to speculate on
what he's doing with that banana on
camera
much less what'll do with it off camera
but we all know
damn well what kinds of speculation the
media would be doing if the politics
were reversed here
the explosions of outrage would be
nuclear
the offender would have already issued
multiple tearful apologies
which would not be enough to stop him
from getting dropped from every project
and partnership he's a part of
that's how it would go but because
candace is a conservative none of that
applies
in fact harry styles he could probably
actually come out and say that he meant
it in a racist way
and it still wouldn't bother anyone on
the left or in the media because they
believe that if you're a conservative
you don't deserve basic human decency so
no treatment towards you can be out of
bounds
you could be shot dead as we've seen
by some antifa radical in the street and
they still won't say that you didn't
deserve it
so this goes for racist treatment too of
course and this is
double true for female conservatives and
black conservatives
and doubly doubly true for black female
conservatives because
they're not only horrible people for
being conservative but they're also
traitors
as the logic goes third point
you know i'm talking about conservatives
here but candace's original point
is not really a conservative point it's
not a political point
it's just a normal natural human
healthy observation
she's saying that she wants men to be
masculine
she wants men to live up to their
masculine potential
that's what she wants from men as a
woman
and i got news for you that's what
almost all women who have ever lived on
earth have wanted from men
that's not to say that all women have
the same taste in men
but generally speaking almost all women
the vast vast majority
since the dawn of human civilization
have desired that men be masculine
strong protectors providers
more stoic and rational than emotional
and sensitive
there are varying degrees there are
different tastes and priorities of
course
but there are also general statements we
can make about what most women
have wanted in men throughout history
just as there are general statements we
can make about what most men have wanted
in women
again since the dawn of time most men
have wanted women who are affectionate
maternal feminine empathetic caretakers
etc
now we can i suppose discuss whether
these ideals are good or right or
whatever
i would say they absolutely are good and
right and that societies which produce
feminine women and masculine men tend to
thrive in fact societies cannot thrive
unless there is
some kind of general idea about what
roles men and women are supposed to play
within it
but my point even before we get to the
discussion about whether these
traditional gender role
role ideas are right is simply that they
are entirely normal
and natural and human candace owens in
saying that
she finds it ridiculous and off-putting
when men
prance around in women's clothes is
expressing the view
of literally billions of women on earth
past and present
the left reacts to this normal
expression this normal view
not just by calling it wrong but by
acting as though it's insane
irrational bizarre crazy you aren't just
incorrect for thinking that men
shouldn't cross-dress you're a freak a
weirdo a nut job
this is the game they play they do the
same thing with drag queen story hour
with
children being given hormone pills
people declaring themselves to be gender
queer pansexual aliens or whatever
they are the ones introducing this
bizarre and disturbing thing
but they act like you are the eccentric
wacko if you don't immediately accept it
they want to make normalcy seem abnormal
they seek to make what is natural seem
perverse and what is perverse
seem natural it is a massive game of
overcompensation you could say
and as a tactic it's extremely effective
you know they do something weird like
have a
drag queens dressed like tim burton
character show up to the library to read
lgbt propaganda to four-year-olds
and if you say yeah you know i don't
think i really
am in favor of this i don't i don't like
it
they go what you have a problem with
this
you don't like this what what are you
some kind of degenerate
and it works lots of people upon
receiving that reaction
throw up their hands and say okay okay
never mind do what you want jeez
all right i forget i said anything
that's that is essentially what what
most of america says to the left it's
they don't agree with them they just say
all right just fine do what you want
few people have the gumption and the
guts to be met with that onslaught and
to say
yes i do have a problem with it now stop
being hysterical
you're the degenerate it's not me get
this crap out of the library
very few will do that even though the
vast majority of people think it's weird
and creepy
few will say it out loud and even fewer
will keep saying it even when the
pitchfork mob shows up at their door
and so the left gets away with making
what is normal abnormal and what is
abnormal normal
they are trying to cancel normalcy in
effect
but today they are cancer instead
for what it's worth which admittedly
probably is not much
but there it is hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated